[संगीत]
[प्रशंसा]
ए
[संगीत]
हेलो एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग दोस्तों एक बार
सभी लोग यह बता दीजिए की मेरी आवाज ए रही
है नहीं ए रही
लेडी दे दीजिए आवाज की
उसके बाद हम फरदर स्टार्ट करते हैं जो भी
लास्ट क्लास में हमने जो जहां पर टॉपिक
छोड़
ओके थैंक यू
अकादमी के युटुब चैनल पर तो एक बार बता
दीजिए की लास्ट क्लास में हमने क्या कर
किया था कहां पर लास्ट क्लास हमने और की
थी इसी को याद हो तो कंटीन्यूअस आते हैं
जिनके एक दो के नाम मुझे याद है
रियली कैसे सच में फेसबुक और सेंड कंप्लीट
हो गया था मैंने ऐसा बोला था
कुमार ओझा जी हम लपसोल करेंगे और काफी
मीडियम लेवल सॉल्व करेंगे जिसमें हमारे सब
कुछ उसे होगा इमेज रिवर्स भी गूगल
डार्लिंग भी साड़ी चीज उसमें इंवॉल्व हो
जाएगी उसे चीज की चिंता करने की आपको मेरे
पहले ही प्लेन में है लेकिन अभी आप अपने
लेटेस्ट न्यूज़ जब नहीं होगी ग्रुप में
तो वह डिसाइड करेगा आप लोगों के लिए आपका
फ्यूचर इन डी हो ओपन सोशल इंटेलिजेंस में
वैसे अगर मैं चाहूं तो ओपन सोशलटेलिजेंस
को इतना जल्दी खत्म करना नहीं चाहता
क्योंकि ओपन सोशल इंटेलिजेंस में आपको लिए
बहुत कुछ बच्चा हुआ है और काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग चीज बच्ची हुई हैं जो आपको
पता हनी चाहिए तो यह आप लोग डिपेंड करता
है की आप किस तरीके से आप चाहते हो किस
तरीके से आप इनफॉरमेशन चाहते हो की इस तरह
का कोर्स चाहते हो क्योंकि एवं आप यह
कोर्स कहानी पर करने भी जाते हैं इतना
डिटेल कोर्स आपको नहीं जाता क्योंकि मैं
अगर आप लोगों को अगर चाहे तो आप लोग थैंक
यू बोलना चाहिए मुझे की मैंने आपके ₹1000
बावा दिए क्योंकि अगर ओनली ओपन सोशल
इंटेलिजेंस आप किसी प्लेटफॉर्म
कंटिन्यू करते हैं की आप लोग लास्ट टॉपिक
याद नहीं की लास्ट टॉपिक मैंने कहां पर
बताया था तो मुझे याद है क्योंकि आज की
क्लास जो है आज की क्लास में हर बार के
टूल्स हैं आज की क्लास में भर भर के टूल्स
हैं और जितने भी टूल्स इस क्लास में
करवाएं जाएंगे तो उसकी आपको एक टेक्स्ट
फाइल बनाकर आपको जो अपना ग्रुप है इसका
टेलीग्राम का ग्रुप है उसमें आपको
प्रोफाइल शेर कर दी जाएगी जल्दी क्लास और
होने के बाद या उसे टाइम के बाद
चलो हम स्टार्ट करते हैं
क्योंकि आपको पता है फेसबुक ओपनटेलिजेंस
क्या होता है और टेक्निकल नॉन टेक्निकल
दोनों ही हमारे पहले चल रहा है टेक्निकल
में हम इंटर कर चुके हैं तो सर सर हम क्या
करने वाले हैं प्रैक्टिकल करने वाले हैं
तो चलते हैं
ओपन हो राखी है और हमारा टारगेट लास्ट में
क्या था मार्क जकरबर्ग हमारे टारगेट थे
क्योंकि हम जो मटर कंपनी
के बड़े में इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग करने के
लिए जो काफी हेल्प करते हैं आपको टेक्निकल
मेथड तरीके से इनफॉरमेशन कलेक्ट करने के
लिए किसी भी टारगेट के बड़े में तो आज हम
बढ़ते हैं क्योंकि आपके सामने एक चैलेंज ए
रहा था बार-बार की अगर आपको
तो अगर किसी भी टारगेट के लिए अगर इवेंट
आईडी निकाल चाहिए या पेज आईडी चाहिए या
ग्रुप आईडी चाहिए तो आप कैसे फाइंड आउट
करोगे आपको लोकेशन आईडी मैंने बता दिया
कैसे फाइंड आउट करते हैं आपको पता चल गया
होगा
लास्ट लास्ट में मैंने आपको फाइंड आउट
करके दिखाए था अगर इवेंट आईडी है या पेज
आईडी या ग्रुप आइडिया हमें फाइंड आउट करना
है तो हम कैसे कर सकते हैं क्योंकि हमने
एक टूल का उसे किया था वो टूल कल लास्ट
क्लास में तो कम कर नहीं रहा था आज की कोई
करण ही नहीं है नो इशू हमें कम करते हैं
फिर से की आपको जाते हैं एक बार मैं क्या
करता हूं आपको ओपन करके दिखता हूं मेरे
लास्ट जो नोट्स अगर शेव्ड है तो ओपन आईटी
ओपन
कैसे फाइंड आउट करोगे तो हम पहले फेसबुक
चलते हैं
कोई भी ग्रुप आईडी फाइंड आउट करनी है अगर
आपका टारगेट किसी भी ग्रुप में एड है तो
आप क्या कर रहा है वो आईडी फाइंड आउट कर
सकते हो या कैसे कर सकते हो देखो ये है की
मैं पर एग्जांपल में कोई भी इवेंट है
क्या करता हूं मैं जाता हूं
मैं प्रोफाइल पेज मेरा यही है अबाउट में
जाता हूं ऑफ पर एग्जांपल मेरा लाइव इवेंट
कोई भी इवेंट है क्लिक करता हूं और मैं
अगर
वॅटीवर ऑन डी बेसिस हमने
इवेंट इन्होंने जो है शो किया हुआ है
ओपन किया है देखो अब मुझे क्या करना है की
इस इवेंट की आईडी चाहिए होती है चाहिए
क्योंकि टारगेट को मेंशन करने और उसमें
मेंशन करने के लिए टारगेट के बड़े में
इनफॉरमेशन करने के लिए मैं कैसे फाइंड आउट
करूंगा राइट क्लिक करूंगा
व्यू पे सॉल्व करके यहां पर क्या है सर्च
करना काफी टिपिकल काफी बढ़िया अमाउंट में
कौन सा है हम क्या करते हैं कंट्रोल
करेंगे कंट्रोल सी करेंगे
और यहां पर कंट्रोल अप करेंगे और उसके बाद
यहां पे क्या सर्च करेंगे हम सर्च करेंगे
पता नहीं यह कम करने में क्या है की मेरा
इधर ही है आउट हो जाता है इस सिस्टम
मैंने बताया था की कैसे हमने लोकेशन आईडी
फाइंड आउट की थी कैसे हमने यूजर आईडी
फाइंड आउट की थी तो यूजर की आईडी है इस
तरीके से आप इवेंट आईडी फाइंड आउट कर सकते
हैं कैसे करना है किसी भी इवेंट पर जाइए
वहां पर राइट क्लिक कीजिए व्यू पेज सोर्स
कीजिए कोड को कॉपी कीजिए फाइल ओपन कीजिए
अभी ये फाइल क्या कर रही है हमारी हैंग कर
दिया दूसरा ऑप्शन आपको पता है अगर आप
लोगों ने नेक्स्ट शिखा हो तो हम इसको का
सकते हैं किसी भी टेक्स्ट फाइल में इसको
से करेंगे उसके बाद ग्रेप कमांड का उसे
करके अभी हम क्या बहुत इजी से इजीली फाइंड
आउट कर सकते हैं अभी यहां पर देखने को
नहीं मिल रहा था ग्रिप कमांड से भी ये
फाइंड आउट कर सकते हैं लेकिन उसके लिए
हमें
कमांड लाइन को उसे करना होगा
ये हमारा ये कोई भी पेज है हम इसको क्लोज
कर देता हूं तो यहां पर क्या करते हैं
तो आपका ग्रुप में लिस्ट अपडेट हो गई होगी
देखिए आप लोगों को ग्रुप में लिस्ट अपडेट
हो गए हो जितने भी टूल्स हैं आज के क्लास
में जो कर होंगे तो वहां से आप देख सकते
हो तो आप क्या करोगे पेज पर जाओगे
कितना भी हैंगिंग होना चाहिए मेरे भाई
चलते हैं पहले पर एग्जांपल हम क्या करते
हैं अभी हम
उसके बाद क्या है
अगर आपको क्या करना है पहले बात तो यह
यूजर आईडी यहां पे देखने को मिलेगी अगर
कोई भी इवेंट बताते हैं ये पर एग्जांपल
कोई भी इवेंट होगा या कोई भी आईडी कहां से
मिलती है आपको पता है वहां पर
है पर एग्जांपल मैं क्या करता हूं
[संगीत]
मी मशीन इस गोइंग तू सो मैच थैंक यू
आपको वैसे बता देता हूं एक कम ध्यान से
सुनिए एक बार आप एक चीज को ध्यान से सुनिए
तरीका वही है आपको क्या करना है किसी भी
पेज पे जाना है पेज पे जान के बाद क्या
करना है की उसे राइट क्लिक करना है व्यू
व्यू पे शोस करना और वहां पर पेज आईडी
सर्च करना है एवं आपको ग्रुप पे जाना है
तो अगर हो सकता है की पर एग्जांपल आपको
पता है की जो आपका कोई भी टारगेट है वो
किसी भी ग्रुप का हिस्सा है किसी भी ग्रुप
में एड है तो आपका क्या करना है ग्रुप पे
क्लिक करना है और उसे ग्रुप में क्या-क्या
वाइड क्लिक करना है फिर ग्रुप पार्टी सर्च
करना है तो आपको ग्रुप आईडी भी देखने को
मिल जाएगी क्योंकि देखो अभी मैं आपके
सामने करके दिखाऊंगा क्योंकि यहां पर क्या
है इसी फेस में हमारे सिस्टम क्या है
बेसिकली हैंग कर रहा है क्योंकि यहां पर
कुछ इशू है बड़े-बड़े पोर्ट्स की सो रही
है पता नहीं आई डोंट नो की यहां पर मेरी
मशीन के साथ क्या हो रहा है तो प्लीज आप
लोग एक बार चाट में बता दीजिए की क्या ये
हो जाएगा अगर मैं आप लोगों की इवेंट आईडी
पेज आईडी और ये सब कहां पे मिलेगी आपको
पेज सोर्स करके ही मिलेंगे आपको वहां पर
क्या करोगे कंट्रोल अप करोगे तो तभी आपको
ये देखने को मिलेगी क्योंकि देखो इवेंट
रेडी फाइंड आउट करने के लिए आपको क्या
करना पड़ेगा इवेंट भी मेंशन करना और जैसे
मैंने अभी ओपन किया था
अगर आपको प्रो और अगर आपको ग्रुप आईडी
फाइंड आउट करनी है तो आपका टारगेट पहले
बात तो उसे ग्रुप में एड होना चाहिए किसी
भी ग्रुप का अगर पार्ट है या किसी ग्रुप
में उसे ग्रुप में क्या करना है या आपको
ऐसा लगता है की अब इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग की
है तो आप को कुछ ऐसे
इन्वेस्टिगेशन में आपने ऐसा लगा की हां इस
ग्रुप का पार्ट हो सकता है क्या करना है
उसे ग्रुप पे जाना है जब आपको पता है बहुत
सारे ग्रुप होते हैं आपको पता है फेसबुक
पे बहुत सारे ग्रुप होते हैं ना उसे ग्रुप
के पेज पर जाना है वहां पे क्या करना है
आपको आ राइट क्लिक करना ग्रुप आईडी करना
है तो ग्रुप आईडी वहां से भी पार्टी देखने
को मिल जाएगी इसी तरीके से आप हरेक आईडी
के बड़े में पता कर दो क्योंकि देखो जो
कैटिगरीज है वो एग्जांपल पेज भी करता है
की तो पेज पे जाके आप पेज कैटिगरी पेज
आईडी फाइंड आउट कर सकते हैं इवेंट कौन से
है जो जो शेर किया हैं उन्होंने
इवेंट्स है तो वहां से आपको क्या देखने को
मिल शक्ति है इवेंट आईडी यहां पे आइडिया
ग्रुप आइडिया देखने को मिल शक्ति है
एडरवाइज यही मुझे टैकल करने में काफी टाइम
ग रहा है
लास्ट क्लास में मैंने आपको दिखाए वैसे
क्योंकि मैंने लास्ट क्लास में क्या बताया
था आपको की जो मैंने टारगेट जो आपका
टारगेट की आईडी है टारगेट मतलब पे जो
टारगेट कौन सा है जो यूजर नाम आईडी है
उसके बेसिस पे मैंने आपको बताया है
हम टाइम वेस्ट नहीं करेंगे ओके इस पर हम
ज्यादा टाइम वेस्ट नहीं करने वाले हम
डायरेक्टली आप सर्च करने वाले वाले
मार्क्स
चलो ये मार्क ये आपको पता चल गया होगा
अब एक बात सोचिए एक बात सोचिए की अगर पर
एग्जांपल आपने जितने भी टूल्स उसे किया
लास्ट अभी तक जितने भी टूल्स उसे किया हैं
अब वो टूल्स ने अपना कम नहीं किया और
टूल्स के बेसिस पे आप इनफॉरमेशन का देंगे
नहीं कर का रहे या टूल्स पे वर्किंग
कंडीशन में नहीं है बट क्या है वे आर डी
एथिकल हैकर्स अब हम ऐसे नहीं होते की किसी
एक टूल टूल पे डिपेंड होकर र जाएंगे
क्योंकि हम किसी भी एक टूल पे डिपेंड होकर
नहीं रहते हम उसके लिए फिर क्या हमारे पास
सॉल्यूशन क्या होता है मैन्युअल तरीका उसे
करते हैं अब मैन्युअल तरीके में मैं आपको
सिखाऊंगा की जो यूआरएल होते हैं
तो यूआरएल होते हैं ना हो तू
मैन्युफैक्चरिंग विद डी यूआरएल यूआरएल
उसके साथ कैसे करते हैं
तो आपको हो तू
मैनिपुलेट फेसबुक
[संगीत]
अब यह क्या चीज देखने को मैया दिखाने वाला
हूं देखिए
फोटोस वीडियो मार्केट प्लेस पेज प्लेस
ग्रुप इवेंट्स आपको ये साड़ी चीज देखने को
मिल रही होगी और जो भी अभी तक हमने टूल
उसे किया वो सारे इन्हीं के बेसिस पे क्या
करते हैं आपको सर्च रिजल्ट प्रोवाइड करते
हैं अभी फेसबुक के पेज के अंदर ही आपको
प्रोवाइड करते हैं जस्ट वो क्या है की
फेसबुक को उसे करते हैं टेक्निकल तरीके से
पापा हम क्या करते हैं की आपने बस
कीवर्ड्स पुटिंग कर देते हैं और कुछ जो
एक्स्ट्रा डीटेल्स है कोई आईडी है वहां पर
मेंशन करते हैं लोकेशन आईडी या टारगेट
आईडी या पोस्ट आईडी वहां पर मेंशन करते
हैं
मेंशन करते हैं तो वह आपको
इनफॉरमेशन प्रोवाइड करता है लेकिन अलग-अलग
पेज पर जाके हलक टूल्स का अलग-अलग तरीका
होता है आउटपुट शो करने का अलग-अलग
अपने-अपने कैपेबिलिटी होती है तो ये साड़ी
जो ये चीज मैं आपको ये चीज देखने को मिल
रहे होंगे देखो आपको जो भी ये चीज देखने
को मिलती है ना ये इसको हम बोलते हैं
कैटिगरीज ये साड़ी की साड़ी क्या होती है
कैटिगरी होती है और हर एक कैटिगरी के अंदर
कोई कम आप पोस्ट करता हूं तो हर एक
कैटिगरी के अंदर क्या होती है तब कैटिगरीज
भी होती है और एक कैटिगरी के अंदर क्या
होती है पोस्ट करता हूं तो सब कैटिगरीज भी
आपको देखने को मिलती है अगर मैं पीपल करता
हूं तो यह है एक कैटिगरी है और इसके अंदर
भी सब कटेगी फ्रेंड्स सिटी एजुकेशन
होती है आपको देखने को मिलती हैं तो अगर
मैं यहां पर
फ्रेंड्स करता हूं और एनिमल में करता हूं
यहां पर
अन्योन करता हूं और ओके मैं एक कम करता
हूं
यार क्या फेसबुक कुछ भी शो कर देता है तो
अभी क्या है तो हम क्या करते देखो या कोई
और देखने को मिल रहा होगा मैं इसको
कंट्रोल सी करता हूं और एक बार आप में
नोटबुक में ले चला हूं देखो कंट्रोल बी
करता हूं अभी एक चीज दिखता हूं आपको
जो फर्स्ट में आपको यह दिखाई दे रहा था यह
चीज कंट्रोल सी करता हूं और नेक्स्ट लाइन
में चलते हैं ये जो ये चीज है ना आपको ये
क्या दिखाई दे रही है कंट्रोल भी ये क्या
है आपका ये क्या है आपका प्रोटोकॉल है
इसको हम बोलते हैं प्रोटोकॉल पी आर ओ टी ओ
सी ओ ल इसको बोलते हैं प्रोटेंस नेक्स्ट
लाइन में जो आपको देखने को मिल रहा है ये
यहां पर जो देखने को मिल रहा है इसको हम
बोलते हैं जो ये भी है ओनली ये इसको हम
बोलते हैं कंट्रोल सी
कंट्रोल भी इसको हम बोलेंगे हम
अरे यार
इसको बोलेंगे हम डोमेंस या तो इसको हम
बोलेंगे डोमेन या सब डोमेन बोलेंगे अब
रोमांस रोमांस
चीजों को उसे करना है तो यहां पे उसका पाठ
है अब उसके बाद नेक्स्ट देखने को मिल रहा
होगा ये चीज ये चीज आपको देखने को मिल रही
है ये चीज इसको हम बोल रहे हैं यहां पर
क्या है कंट्रोल सी इसको हम बोलते हैं
कंट्रोल भी इसको बोलते हम क्या आपको
कैटिगरी यह वह कैटिगरी जिसकी मैं बात कर
रहा था आपको देखने को मिल रहा था यहां पर
होती है कैटिगरी आपको देखने को मिलती है
नीचे जो आपको क्यों इक्वल तू ये क्वेश्चन
मार्क देखने को मिलता है मतलब यहां पर करी
कर रहा हूं की इसके बेसिस पर यहां पर आपको
कीवर्ड्स के कीवर्ड्स या बेसिस पे आपको
इनफॉरमेशन करते हैं ये शब्द यहां पर क्या
मेंशन करते हैं हम ए शब्द ए शब्द एवर्स आप
यहां पर मेंशन करते हैं
बड़े में पुरी कर रहे हैं क्यों मतलब करी
कर रहे हैं उसके बाद इक्वल तू मार्क इक्वल
तू हमारा कीवर्ड्स हम यहां पर मेंशन करते
हैं कई बार आपको यहां पे एक और चीज देखने
को मिलेगी यहां साथ में और यहां पर देखने
को मिलेगा और उसके बाद आपको क्या देखने
वाला फिल्टर एफ आई ल टी ल फिल्टर इक्वल और
कोई भी रेंडम वैल्यू पर एग्जांपल
देखने को मिलेगी
तो अब यह जो आपको देखने को मिल रहा है
क्योंकि देखो यह एक फिल्टर अप्लाई कर गया
फिल्टर क्या होता है फिल्टर यह होता है
जिसके बेसिस पे हम क्या कर रहे हैं पोस्ट
क्योंकि यह कैटिगरी है कैटिगरी के अंदर जो
भी सब कैटिगरी है ना कैटिगरी के अंदर मैं
आपको बताता हूं जारी जो है आपको पीपल में
करता हूं पीपल के अंदर क्या है ये रहा
पीपल्स हैं फोटो ट ये रहा फ्रेंड आनेवन मी
फ्रेंड ये भी ये क्या सब कैटिगरी है यह
क्या फिल्टर्सिनी के बेस्ट में हम क्या
करते हैं फिल्टर अप्लाई करते हैं यानी की
बेस हम क्या करते हैं फिल्टर अप्लाई करते
हैं तो ये क्या होता है ये फिल्टर होता है
और ये जो चीज आपको देखने को मिल रही है ये
जो चीज देख रहे हैं तो आपको मिल रही है ये
भी जो चीज देखने को थे यहां पर जो आपको
देखना मिलता है फिल्टर के आगे यहां पर
मिलता है आपको बेस 64 में आपको फिल्टर
करके देखने को क्या मिलता है बेस 64 इनको
मिलता है यहां पर
इनकोडेड मिलता है यहां पर जो वैल्यू मिलती
है ना वैल्यू
मिलती है लेकिन इसके पीछे जो वैल्यू होती
है जो यहां पर जो भी है जिसकी भी वैल्यू
है या जो इनकॉर्डेड कर राखी है आगे इसकी
जो वैल्यू निकलेंगे इसको डिकोड करेंगे तो
यहां पर होती है
साड़ी की साड़ी तो ये आपको समझ में ए गया
होगा ये वाला क्या होता है
जेसन होता क्या है यह बता दो पहले
64 में क्यों किया जाता है
यह होता है जावास्क्रिप्ट ऑब्जेक्ट
इनकोड फॉर्म में लेट है
इस के बेस पर प्रोसेस करता है अगर आप
डायरेक्टली
कर डॉग करी के अंदर यूआरएल के अंदर तो
क्या करें वहां पर एरर देखने को मिलेगी
आपको कोई भी रिजल्ट शो करके नहीं दें
दिखाएगा आपको कोई भी रिजल्ट आपको शो करके
नहीं दिखाएगा जस्ट ओनली वहां पर कोई भी
रेंडम एरर आपको शो करते हैं यार भी नहीं
आएगी बस कुछ भी फायदा करके नहीं दिखाएगा
लेकिन अगर आप उसको क्या करोगे जेसन
फॉर्मेट में जो भी आप फाइंड आउट करने की
कोशिश कर रहे हो उसको जब एक बार बेस्ट 64
में कन्वर्ट करके आप फिल्टर करोगे तो आपको
वो आपकी तरह से आउटपुट शो करेगा तो हम वो
कैसे उसे करेंगे अभी क्योंकि हम यूआरएल को
मेनू प्लेट कैसे करेंगे देखो ये है यूआरएल
के बड़े में जो अब आपको बताना चाहता है ये
जो साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन अगर मैं आपको बताऊं
यहां पर एक मिनट इंटर कर देता हूं तो आपको
अच्छे से क्लियर समझ में ए जाएगी ये क्या
किया मैंने आपको बताया तो क्वेश्चन मार्क
और ये फिल्टर और मैं ऑलरेडी बताई ये साड़ी
डीटेल्स क्या है इसके बेसिक मैंने क्या
किया आपको यहां पर एक्सप्लेन कर दिया आई
होप सबको समझ में ए गया होगा अब बात करते
हैं हम चलते हैं
एक मेरे पास है डॉक्यूमेंट आपको मिल गया
होगा अगर मैं आपको बोलूं अगर आपको
डॉक्यूमेंट मिल गया होगा तो अभी मैं चला
हूं आपको ये रहा
एक ये लिंक है अगर आपके पास एक मिल गया
होगा तो इसको ओपन कीजिए तो यहां पर सब कुछ
मेंशन आपको यहां पर वो सब कुछ मेंशन है जी
तरीके से आप क्या करोगे अपने जो करीज हैं
जो आपकी फेसबुक कमेंट करने वाली वीडियो
वहां इसी के बेस पर आप कम करो देखो यहां
पर क्या है वो आपको मैं बताया की आपको खुद
से ही पढ़ना पड़ेगा तो अभी देखिए आपको
यहां देखना था की 1 मिनट सर्च और टॉप
देखने को मिला था सर्च और टॉप देखने को
मिलेगा सर्च क्या बताया था पाठ है टॉप
मतलब है और जब मैंने क्या किया जब हम उसे
करते हैं तो मैं क्या करता हूं ओपन कर
देता हूं उसके अंदर तो मैं का देता हूं
कंट्रोल
भी कंट्रोल
क्योंकि आपके पास मैंने सारे टूल्स की
इनफॉरमेशन दे दी अब ये देखो ये टॉप है
मैंने जब यहां पे ओपन किया था यहां पर
क्या देखा टॉप देखने को मिला था टॉप कौन
सी कैटिगरी होती है जब आपने फेसबुक में जो
किया ना जो जब जो कर यहां पर टॉप देखने को
मिलेगा पोस्ट करूंगा आपको पोस्ट चेंज हो
जाएगा पीपल करूंगा तो यहां पे पीपल के रूप
में चेंज हो जाएगा कैटिगरी चेंज हो जाएगी
तो इसी तरीके से यहां पर क्या है ये
कैटिगरीज है ये इसके अंदर सब कैटिगरी
शॉर्ट बाय कर आप मोस्ट रिसेंट के बेसिस पे
सर्च करना चाहते हैं आप पोस्ट फ्रॉम पोस्ट
फ्रॉम यू पोस्ट फ्रॉम योर फ्रेंड्स पोस्ट
फ्रॉम योर ग्रुप और पेज पोस्ट फ्रॉम
पब्लिक पोस्ट फ्रॉम पेज पोस्ट टाइप में
क्या है सीन पोस्ट इन ग्रुप ये एक और तब
कैटिगरीज है तो देखो ये आपको देखना है
इसके अंदर भी सब कटेगी जब मोस्ट रिसेट
मोस्ट फ्रॉम और उसके बाद क्या पोस्ट टाइप
पोस्ट इन ग्रुप पोस्टेड इन ग्रुप लोकेशन
की जब भी आपके पास कोई भी जशन फॉर्मेट है
तो आपको एक चीज ध्यान में रखती है की उनके
बीच में कोई भी स्पेस नहीं होना चाहिए कोई
भी स्पेस नहीं होना चाहिए उनके बीच में तो
कोई भी स्पेस नहीं होना चाहिए तो इसका
मतलब क्या है ये कॉपी कीजिए हमारे पास
सारे टूल्स है मेरे पास नेक्स्ट टूल उसे
करने वाला हूं अगर मैं आपको बात करूं देखो
जेसन क्या होता है अगर आप पढ़ना चाहते हो
तो यहां पे पढ़ सकते हो आपको ये लिंक
प्रोवाइड कर दिया है उसके बाद क्या ये रहा
ये वाला ये वाला ओपन करता हूं कंट्रोल सी
करता हूं और अपनी मशीन को ओपन करते हैं हम
यहां पर कंट्रोल भी किया है मैंने ये
टेंडर
पेस्ट कर देता हूं यहां पे मैंने कर दिया
पेस्ट अब मैंने यहां पे पेस्ट किया नो नो
नो नो यहां पर पेस्ट मैंने ये वाला को
पेस्ट कर दिया नो फिर से कॉपी करते हैं
इसको कॉपी करते हैं
पेस्ट करते हैं
अब क्या क्या हमें नहीं पता इसके अंदर
स्पेस ए गया क्या ए गया आई डोंट नो हम
क्या करते हैं यहां पर
जाते हैं
कंपैक्ट मतलब नो स्पेस उसके बाद क्या करते
हैं प्रोसेस कर देते हैं जैसे हम प्रोसेस
करेंगे
जैसे ही वैलिड आया फिर आप यहां से भी क्या
कर सकते हो देखो यहां पे ऑप्शन कॉपी तू
क्लिपबोर्ड अपने कॉपी किया जब आपने कॉपी
कर लिया उसके बाद आपको क्या करना है बेस
64 में कन्वर्ट भी करना है उसके लिए आपके
पास एक और वेबसाइट है कंट्रोल सी करता हूं
मैं और उसके बाद मैं एक बार कंट्रोल भी
करता हूं इधर कंट्रोल भी करता हूं इसको
ओपन कर देता हूं उसके बाद मैं फिर से इसको
एक बार कॉपी करता हूं कॉपी किया मैंने और
यहां पे क्या कर देना मैंने इनको एड करना
है मुझे तो मैं जस्ट सिंपली कर रहा हूं
पेस्ट किया मैंने उसके बाद मैं क्या करता
हूं यहां पर कुछ भी करने की जरूर है क्या
कर दो मैंने यहां से क्या कर दिया और यहां
पे देखना है ये आपकी इनको ड्यूटी वैल्यू
देखने को मिल रही होगी अब यहां से आप क्या
करते हैं कॉपी तू क्लिपबोर्ड कॉपी तू
क्लिपबोर्ड किया उसके बाद क्या करना है
आपको अभी आपके पास मार्क
जिसकी में कैटिगरी कौन सी थी टॉप ठीक है
और इसके अंदर से हमने ये उठाया है इसके सब
कैटिगरी से जो भी फिल्टर सब अप्लाई करना
चाहते हैं तो हम क्या करें यूआरएल पर
जाएंगे उसके बाद यहां पर पहले तो हम चेंज
करेंगे तो पहले तो हम यहां क्या चेंज
करेंगे तो यहां पर क्या करेंगे चेंज यहां
हो गया आ टॉप हो गया उसके बाद क्यों
क्वेश्चन मार्क उसके बाद हम क्या अप्लाई
करेंगे हम और उसके बाद क्या अप्लाई करेंगे
आई एम राइट की मैं सही लिख रहा हूं या
नहीं लिख रहा हूं मैं एक बार देख लेट हूं
मैंने इसको ओके उसके बाद हम और उसके बाद
हमारा और हो गया दें हम अप्लाई करेंगे
फिल्टर एफ आई ल टी ए ल फिल्टर दें इक्वल
साइन उसके बाद कंट्रोल बी
ओके कंट्रोल भी यहां कम नहीं तो हम क्या
करें पेस्ट कर देंगे
अभी देखना इस के बेसिस पे ये आंसर आपको शो
करेगा देख उसके बेसिस पे ही आंसर शो कर
देगा देखो ये वही ए रहा है जो मोस्ट
रिसेंटली वहां पे पहले भी सिलेक्ट था इसी
के बेसिस पास में शो हो रहा है अगर आपको
दूसरे तरीके से और भी देखना है देखो अब
मैं क्या देखा हूं की पोस्ट फ्रॉम यू
पोस्ट फ्रॉम यू ये बेसिस पे हम क्या पोस्ट
फ्रॉम योर ग्रुप और पेज के बेसिस पे मैं
चाहता हूं यहां पर कुछ प्रोवाइड तो नहीं
करना हाइट चाहिए ध्यान रखना जैसे पोस्ट
फॉर्म पेज करना है तो उसके लिए आपको पेज
के भी क्या चाहिए आपको पेज यहां पर जो
आईडी मेंशन की हुई है पेज आईडी चाहिए आपको
पेज आईडी चाहिए ना तो आपको पेज आईडी कैसे
मेंशन करनी होगी पेज आइडिया आपको फाइंड
आउट करने है क्योंकि मैंने आपको बताया की
पेज आईडी इवेंट आईडी या वो ग्रुप आईडी
कैसे फाइंड आउट करनी है आपको पता है तो
यहां पर क्या करना है आप सिंपली क्या
करोगे जब इसको कॉपी करोगे
और उससे पहले फॉर्मेट में लेकर जाते हो
उसको स्पेस रिमूव करने के लिए वहां पे इस
वैल्यू को क्या कर सकते हो आप चेंज कर
सकते हो तो पर एग्जांपल अभी मैं क्या कर
रहा हूं यहां पर
एक कम करना चाहता हूं
लोकेशन के लिए भी आपको क्या करना पड़ेगा
लोकेशन
आपको दिखता हूं मैं
उसके लोकेशन
पेस्ट कर देना है उसके बाद आपको करना है
मार्क्स अगर क पर जाना है क्योंकि मार्क
है उसका लोकेशन आईडी पहले हमें चाहिए ना
लोकेशन आईडी के लिए हम क्या करते हैं पहले
पांच पेड़ जाते हैं नेक्स्ट ओके क्लिक
नेक्स्ट क्लिक क्लिक उसके बाद हम क्या
करते हैं मार्च की प्रोफाइल से प्रोफाइल
ओपन करो
इस डी रियल प्रोफाइल हमने कहां घूम कर
दिया इनका
इनफॉरमेशन
स्टूडियो था ना अगर हम देखते हैं थिंग्स
तो दो
कंट्रोल
कर देते हैं
और प्रोसीड किया मैंने उसके बाद क्या किया
कॉपी किया उसके बेस 64 था इससे मैं क्या
करूंगा अभी यहां पर टेस्ट करता हूं
नेक्स्ट मैच
लिया था टैग लोकेशन और कौन सी है ये तो
टॉप से ही है
तो हम क्या करते हैं अभी प्लेस है यहां पे
क्या करते हैं अभी पैक चलते हैं
टेस्ट करते हैं और इंटर करते हैं
इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग कर सकते हो यूआरएल को
मैनिपुलेट करके यह तो एक तरीके से दो
तरीके से मैं आपको करके दिखा दिया है अब
ये क्या है आपको मैंने बता दिया की आपको
हर एक को खुद से ट्राई करना है क्योंकि
अगर आप लोग चाहते हो की मुझे बटर बन्ना
ओपन सोशल ट्रेड जैसे कैसे में आप मुझे
ज्यादा से ज्यादा इनफॉरमेशन निकाल पाऊं तो
आई एम वेरी हैप्पी विथ यू मां चाचा की
लिमिटेड हो तो आपका कम प्रैक्टिस करना ये
डॉक्यूमेंट आपको मिल गया है तो यहां पर ये
डॉक्यूमेंट मेंशन किया हुआ इसमें सब कुछ
लिखा सब कुछ आप पढ़ना है और एक्सपेरिमेंट
करना है नेक्स्ट जयसवाल फॉर्मेट है यहां
पर क्या करना है आपको कन्वर्जन करना है और
जेसन को क्या करना है
और उसके बाद बेस 64 में कोड करना है आपको
सिंपली आपको ये वाला उसके बड़े में मैंने
काफी डिटेल इनफॉरमेशन आपको बता दिए आप इस
तरीके की मैन्यूफ कर सकते हैं वन बाय वन
अब बात करते हैं देखो आपने अभी तो एक ही
यूआरएल को क्या किया
मैंने अपलोड किया अब बात करते हैं की अगर
आपको एक से ज्यादा योर कांबिनेशन उसे कर
रहा हूं अगर पर एग्जांपल आपको फिल्टर का
कांबिनेशन उसे करना तो कैसे करोगे तो एक
चीज ध्यान रखना जब भी आप कांबिनेशन उसे
करोगे तो मैं आपको बता देता हूं जैसे की
ये रहा की मैं आपको एक चीज इनफॉरमेशन
ध्यान रखना की कांबिनेशन याद उसे करने में
ये तो में कैटिगरी है इसके सब कैटिगरीज है
मोस्ट रिसेंड पोस्ट फ्रॉम और उसके बाद
क्या है पोस्ट टाइप तो एक चीज का ध्यान
रखना
एक चीज का आपको ध्यान में रखना है की जब
यह क्या है मैंने कैटिगरी सब कैटिगरी इसके
अंदर क्या है की पोस्ट फ्रॉम यू पोस्ट
फ्रॉम योर फ्रेंड पोस्ट फ्रॉम योर ग्रुप
और दे दीजिए सब कैटिगरीज के क्या है
फिल्टर ने इसके पार्ट है तो अगर आप
मल्टीपल कांबिनेशन उसे करोगे ना तो आप इसे
यहां से एक साथ इन दोनों को उसे नहीं कर
सकते एक ही सब कैटिगरी के अंदर जितने
फिल्टर हैं उनको कांबिनेशन में आप उसे
नहीं कर सकते आप कैसे उसे कर सकते हो ठीक
है आप ऐसे भी कर सकते हो ये में कैटिगरी
है ये सब कैटिगरी है ये सब कैटिगरी है तो
एक इस सब कैटिगरी में से ले सकते हो एक
ऊपर वाली सब कैटिगरी में से ले सकते हो
उनको आपस में क्या कर सकते हो कंबाइन कर
सकते हो लेकिन ऐसा नहीं कर सकते की पोस्ट
फ्रॉम सब कैटिगरी से लेकर आप इसी पोस्ट
फ्रॉम यू से भी एक उठा लिया और दूसरा भी
पोस्ट होंगे फ्रेंड्स से उठा लिया इन
दोनों को आप कभी भी क्या नहीं कर सकते
कंबाइन नहीं कर सकते वो एग्जांपल अगर मैं
आपको दिखाऊंगा मैं उसके बाद क्या आएगी अगर
आपको जैसे पोस्ट टाइप है पोस्ट टाइप के भी
क्या है एक तो पोस्ट टाइप का भी एक है और
पोस्ट इन ग्रुप योर ग्रुप फ्रॉम ग्रुप
यहां पर दो हैं तो अगर आप इन दोनों से एक
को उसे करोगे
इसके भी गए हैं दो पार्ट्स हैं दो फिल्टर
हैं इन दोनों में से कोई भी एक फिल्टरित
कर सकते हो उसके बाद एक इसमें से उसे कर
सकते हैं या इसमें से उसे कर सकते हो इतने
सारे फिल्टर में से या सबसे पहले वाला कोई
भी उसे कर सकते हो लेकिन क्या कर सकते हो
आप में कैटिगरी के अंदर सब कैटिगरी हो सब
कैटिगरी के अंदर फिल्टर हैं तो फिल्टर के
अंदर जो मल्टीपल है बहुत सारे दो तीन कर
पांच फिर जितने उनको आपस में उसे नहीं कर
सकते हैं की क्या कर सकते हैं की दूसरी सब
कैटिगरी के फिल्टर को आप उसे कर सकते हो
लेकिन एक ही उसे कर सकते हो आते ए टाइम
उसका फिल्टर अब कैसे उसे कर सकते हैं देखो
आपको पता है की जब मैं आपको बता यार की जो
आपका जश्न फॉर्मेट है आपका जो जेसन
फॉर्मेट है हम आपको बात करूं की जैसे
फॉर्मेट किस से स्टार्ट होता है
क्लोज कर ले मैसेज अगर आपको अगर देखना है
तो आपको मैंने दिखता हूं यह देखो यह आपका
है
जयपुर
है ये क्लोज है इसकी इसके अंदर क्या है वो
साड़ी की और वैल्यू पर में इनफॉरमेशन है
तो ये देखो ये है आपका ओपन क्लोज तो ये है
एक जेसन फॉर्मेट तो अब मुझे क्या करना है
दो दो उसको
फिल्टर को क्या करना है अगर मुझे एड करना
एक साथ कंबाइन करना मैं कैसे करूं देखो आप
मोसेस से तो एक ही था अब मुझे क्या करना
है की पोस्ट फॉर्म जो सेकंड फील्ड सब
कैटिगरी इसमें से मतलब एक ही ले सकता हूं
इन दो को आपस में कंबाइन नहीं कर सकता जो
सब कैटिगरीज है ना पोस्ट फ्रॉम सब
कैटिगरीज के अंदर क्या है और भी मल्टीपल 1
2 3 4 5 3 5 में से सिर्फ एक ही उसे कर
सकता हूं इन पांच में से दो उसे नहीं कर
सकता अगर आप तीन ही करोगे तो 3 भी करते
वक्त आपको ऐसे ही रखना है की
तीन सब कैटिगरी हनी चाहिए आपके तो मैं एक
कम करता हूं मैं इसको उसे करता हूं पोस्ट
फॉर्म की वाली को मैं क्या करता हूं ओपन
कॉपी किया इनको क्या करना है आपको कंबाइन
कैसे करना है देखो हम आपको सीखना हूं
कंबाइन करने के लिए एक और मैंने इंटर कर
दिया और कंट्रोल भी कर दिया अब ये है ऐसे
हैं दोनों के दोनों ऐसे हैं तो अब मुझे
मैं क्या करता हूं की मैं क्या करता हूं
तो इसको यहां से क्या करता हूं एक लास्ट
वाला जो इसका क्लोज और इसको क्या करता हूं
डिलीट कर देता हूं यहां से इसको जो फ्रंट
वाला है ये जो फ्रंट वाला है इसका जो ओपन
है सेकंड फिल्टर का तो उसका भी मैंने
डिलीट कर दिया उसके बाद मैं क्या करता हूं
बैक करता हूं और और बैक करता हूं और बैक
करता हूं यहां पर ए गया अब यहां पर ए गया
इनके बीच में आपको क्या प्रोवाइड कर देना
एक कोमा अब मैं आपको यहां पर स्पेस
प्रोवाइड कर रहा हूं अब ये मैंने क्या कर
दिया यहां पे स्पेस प्रोवाइड कर रहा हूं
लेकिन यहां पे आपको कोमा जरूर देना है तभी
ये क्या है कांबिनेशन होगा अब यहां पर ये
ओपन है ये क्लोज है फिल्टर बन गया है अगेन
आपको बता देता हूं हमेशा जैसन फोर में
स्टार्ट होता है
और और होता है क्लोज कर लेते हैं अगर
मल्टीप्लेक्स को आपको जोड़ करना मैं
कंट्रोल जा करके दिखा तो आपको यह रहा मेरे
पास
एक और है
एक साथ एड करना है मैं कैसे कर सकता हूं
की मुझे फॉर्मेट में एक ही मेंशन कर सकता
हूं जैसे जेसन फॉर्मेट तो मैं क्या करूंगा
देखो ये ओपन है ये क्लोज है तो मैं क्या
करता हूं जो इसका जो क्लोज फॉर्मेट है
क्लोज जो कर ली रेसिपीज को और जोकली बेसिस
पे करेंगे डिलीट कर दिया इसका जो ओपन
टेलीविजन इसको मैंने क्या डिलीट कर दिया
अब इनको मुझे क्या करना जोड़ना है तो मैं
पहले क्या करता हूं यहां पर एक कोमा लगा
देता हूं उसके बाद वहां पर डायल कर इसको
क्या का रहा हूं मैं जोड़ देता हूं अभी
देखो इनके बीच में स्पेस मेंशन कर रहा हूं
नो इशू करने की जरूर नहीं है इसको हम क्या
है स्पेस रिमूव कर देंगे अब ये मैंने बना
लिया है एक कांबिनेशन ऑफ तू फिल्टर और
मैंने बताया की दोनों अलग-अलग कैटिगरी से
में कैटिगरीज में से दो सब कैटिगरी में से
अलग-अलग में से मैंने क्या किया इसको कॉपी
करता हूं मैं कॉपी करता हूं उसके बाद चलते
हैं हम यहां पर
मैं इसको डिलीट कर दिया कंट्रोल भी कर
दिया मैंने अभी कितना स्पेस भी अपने आप
कंपैक्ट कर देगा या प्रोसेस किया मैंने तो
जैसे प्रॉस्पर देखो वैलिड भी शो कर दिया
अब यहां से मैं क्या करता हूं कॉपी तू
क्लिपबोर्ड करता हूं नेक्स्ट बेस इनकॉर्डर
में चलते हैं यहां से हम क्या करते हैं एक
बार इसको डिलीट कर देते हैं यहां पर पूरा
पूरा डिलीट करते हैं बेस इनकोडर में
64 है यहां पर क्या क्या था कंट्रोल
कंट्रोल करते हैं उसके बाद हम यहां पे
क्या करते हैं इसको इनकॉर्ड कर देते हैं
अभी देखो ये जैसे हमने इसको इनकॉर्ड किया
ये आगे देखो दोनों को एड कर दिया था ना
इसने अब ये इसकी वैल्यू है बेस 64 की
वैल्यू अब मैं ऐसे नहीं करता हूं मैं कॉपी
तू प्ले बोर्ड कर देता हूं नेक्स्ट मैं
चला हूं फिल्टर के अंदर अभी क्या है टॉप
फील्डर से हैं टॉप फाइव फिल्टर है अभी मैं
गैस सिंपली इसको रिमूव कर देता हूं इसकी
वैल्यू को इसको मैं जब रिमूव कर देता हूं
यहां पर ये होगी डिलीट कर देता हूं एक बार
ये ए गया यहां पर कर देता हूं पेस्ट
कंट्रोल बी या पेस्ट कर देता हूं
अभी ये क्या है आपको यही दो फिल्टर के
बेसिस पे आपको शो करेगा इन्हीं दो फिल्टर
के बेसिस पे आपको आउटपुट शो करेगा मोस्ट
रिसेंट प्लस में वह फ्रॉम थिस आईडी और एक
और चीज है की देखो आपको यही से देखने हो
जाएगा अगर मैं कैटिगरी चेंज करता हूं आपके
सामने तो आपको दूसरी कैटिगरी देखने को
मिलेगी तो यहां पर हाईलाइट हो जाए जैसे जो
कैटिगरी से है पोस्ट कैटिगरी से है
कैटिगरी में से अगर बात करें तो ये रहा ये
कौन सी कैटिगरी इस ने उसे की हुई है वहां
से अगर क के लिए तो इस तरीके से देखो यहां
पर मोस्ट रिसेंट ये सब इसमें क्योंकि देखो
ये रहा तो ये आपको देखने का मिलेगा यही पर
हाईलाइट हुआ एक चीज ध्यान में रखना जब
आपने एक बार यूआरएल में मेनू प्लेलिस्ट के
साथ टेक्निक का उसे करते हो तो अगर आप
यहां पर जो सर्च बार है अगर आपने सर्च बार
का उसे किया पर एग्जांपल मैंने क्या पिछली
बार ये वाला मैंने टेक्निकल उसे किया पर
एग्जांपल मैं क्या कर रहा हूं ये रहा ये
इस टेक्निकल मैंने उसे का दिया नहीं मैंने
इस टेक्निकल उसे किया की तंत्र अगर मैंने
इस टेक्निक कोई उसे किया अब मैं अपना
आउटपुट देख लिया अब मैंने क्या कर दिया
मेरे पास ये फिल्टर में मैंने क्या है 10
मिनट में अप्लाई किया कुछ भी मार्क अप्लाई
जो आपका ये वाला मैनिपुलेशन था वो कम नहीं
करेगा
अब वो इस तरह के हिसाब से कम करेगा
एनीथिंग सोशल इंजीनियरिंग इसे डी लास्ट
ऑप्शन
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग आपको उसे करनी पड़ेगी ये
साड़ी चीज क्या है ये प्राइवेट अकाउंट के
बाद क्योंकि किसी ने अपना अकाउंट प्राइवेट
कर लिया तो आपके पास फिर ऑप्शन बंता सोशल
इंजीनियरिंग करना है लेकिन हां प्राइवेट
अकाउंट है तो एक चीज है आपके लिए देखो
जो आपका टारगेट है उसमें प्राइवेट अकाउंट
उसे किया है बट उसके उसका क्या उसके
फ्रेंड्स तो उसके साथ इतने उनके क्लोज
फ्रेंड हो गए या उनके रिलेटिव होंगे
फैमिली मेंबर्स होंगे सभी निंदा का अकाउंट
प्राइवेट नहीं किया होगा ना कोई ना कोई
ऐसा ग्रुप मेंबर मिलेगा या कोई ना कोई ऐसा
फैमिली मेंबर मिलेगा कोई ना कोई ऐसा क्लोज
फ्रेंड मिलेगा जी जिसने अपना अकाउंट
प्रोवाइड प्राइवेट नहीं किया होगा जब उसने
अकाउंट प्राइवेट नहीं किया तो क्या करोगे
देखो उसने अपना अकाउंट प्राइवेट किया
लेकिन दूसरे पर लोगों के साथ क्या आप
जुड़े हुए हो और दूसरा आपका क्या है क्लोज
फ्रेंड है फ्रेंड है तो आप क्या करोगे
उसको अपना टारगेट बनोगे जब उसको आप अपना
टारगेट बनोगे तो आपको क्या करना इनफॉरमेशन
कैसे नहीं करनी है में टारगेट की तो आप
क्या करोगे उसे दूसरे बंदे और जिसको आप
क्या टारगेट बना रहे हो तो उसे पर
इनफॉरमेशन गैस स्टार्ट करोगे उसके बेस पर
आप उसे कीबोर्ड
टाइमलाइन भी फॉलो की गई होगी कहानी ना
कहानी उसका हो सकता है कोई
हो सकता है कुछ ना कुछ वहां पर कुछ
इनफॉरमेशन आपको ऐसे ही मिल जाए जो उसने
भले ही प्राइवेट राखी है बट वो आपके
फ्रेंड के थ्रू आपकी पब्लिक होगी क्योंकि
आप अपने फ्रेंड की गारंटी नहीं दे सकते आप
ऐसे टेक्निक उसे करके देखना आप अपना
अकाउंट प्राइवेट कीजिए और देखो आपने अपना
अकाउंट प्राइवेट किया की आपने सब कुछ
छुपाया लेकिन आप अपने अकाउंट से आपने क्या
कहानी भी कुछ कमेंट किया होगा या कुछ आपने
किसी भी फ्रेंड के क्लोज फ्रेंड के साथ
लोकेशन एक्सपोज कर दिया हो तो कैसे अकाउंट
प्राइवेट अपने अपना खुद का किया लेकिन
फ्रेंड की उसपे लोकेशन
तो आपने वहां एक डायरेक्टली डायरेक्टली
क्या किया अपने आप को भी एक्सपोज कर दिया
आपने अकाउंट ब्लैक प्राइवेट कर दिया हो बट
क्या किया आपने वहां पर खुद को एक्सपोज कर
दिया अपने फ्रेंड के साथ तो आप क्या कर
सुकून उसे कैसे में फ्रेंड के अकाउंट के
थ्रू में टारगेट को टारगेट करोगे क्योंकि
वो फ्रेंड आपको आसानी से मेनू प्लेट हो
जाएगा क्योंकि आप ऐसे बातें करोगे की वो
जैसे की आप उसके फ्रेंड हो उसके फ्रेंड हो
उससे भी इनफॉरमेशन कहते नहीं कर रहा था
आपको पता ना मूवी वाला सीन आपको क्रिएट
करना ही पड़ेगा
तो आपको फ्रेंड के थ्रू भी जाना पड़ेगा
फैमिली मेंबर के थ्रू उसे करता हूं की
इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग करनी पड़ेगी तो वहां भी
आपको काफी कुछ इनफॉरमेशन मिल जाएगी उसके
बाद क्या आप आसानी से उसको उसे कर सकते हो
आई होप की मैं आपका आंसर दे पाया होगा
इसका आंसर बताइए
मनमोहन वी वादा
कैसे उसे कर सकते हो मल्टीप्लेक्स सॉरी
कांबिनेशन में कैसे उसे कर सकते हो इनको
फिल्टर को आप कांबिनेशन में कैसे उसे कर
सकते हो यूआरएल को मैनिपुलेशन टेक्नीशियन
टेक्निक आप सबको समझ में आई या नहीं आई
हां एक चीज नोट ध्यान में रखना की जब आप
यू आर वेरीफिकेशन टेक्निक उसे कर रहे हो
लेकिन जब जो कांबिनेशन वाला उसे कर रहे
हैं ना तो आप ओनली इस में कैटिगरी है ना
जो मैं एक में कैटिगरी है उसे के अंदर
इस के अंदर क्या है की हम क्या कर सकते
हैं
इस के अंदर हम क्या कर सकते हैं उसको
कांबिनेशन में उसे कर सकते हैं जैसे पर
एग्जांपल की मेरा सर्च और टॉप ये एक में
कैटिगरी है इसके अंदर सब कैटिगरीज है तो
इनके जो सब कैटिगरीज हैं उसमें जो कंडीशन
है बताई उसे कंडीशन के साथ मैंने या जो
कंडीशन बताया था की जब कैटिगरी के अंदर जो
फिल्टर है अगर वो मल्टीपल से उनको कंबाइन
नहीं कर सकते लेकिन एक सब कैटिगरी से
दूसरी सब कैटिगरी के फिल्टर को आपका मन कर
सकते हो लेकिन में जो कैटिगरी है में
कैटिगरी के अंदर ही मल्टीप्लेक्स
कांबिनेशन उसे कर सकते हो अब दूसरी में
कैटिगरी के साथ नहीं कर सकते पर एग्जांपल
ये आपके सर्च और टॉप में कैटिगरी है दूसरी
में कैटिगरी आपकी क्या है सर्च और पोस्ट
है तो आप सर्च टॉप के जो फिल्टर है उनको
सर्च पोस्ट के फिल्टर के साथ कंबाइन नहीं
कर सकते ऐसा नहीं कर सकता की मैंने एक
फिल्टर यहां से लिया जो सर्च पोस्ट इसका
में फिल्टर है इसका जो सब फिल्टर है पोस्ट
फ्रॉम यहां से मैंने क्या किया ये उठाया
और इसको मैंने कॉपी किया उसके बाद मैंने
क्या किया यहां से जो टॉप दूसरी में
कैटिगरी यहां से सर यहां से मैंने मोस्ट
रिसेंटली आया पोस्ट फ्रॉम योर फ्रेंड लिया
मैंने यहां से उठा इन दोनों को मैं
मल्टीपल कंबाइन नहीं कर सकता अगर आप 3 से
4 भी कांबिनेशन बना रहे हो तो आपको
कांबिनेशन में कैटिगरी के अंदर ही बनाना
होगा में कैटिगरी के अंदर उसकी सब कैटिगरी
का उसे करते हुए लेकिन आप एक में कटाई से
दूसरी में कटाई दे के बीच में कांबिनेशन
नहीं बना सकते ये आपको हमेशा ध्यान में
रखना होगा तो यह आपका
यूआरएल मैनिपुलेशन टेक्निक आप बात करते
हैं की अगर आपको एक आपको जनरल आइडिया दे
देता हूं मैं आपको अगर आप क्या करना चाहते
हो अपने टारगेट के बड़े में इनफॉरमेशन
गैदरिंग करना चाहते हो तो ये पता करना
चाहते हो की मल्टीप्लेक्स अकाउंट्स है या
नहीं है या उसका कोई अदर अकाउंट है जैसे
की कोई भी ट्विटर या इंस्टाग्राम सॉरी
इंस्टाग्राम अकाउंट है वो पता करने के लिए
आपको एक तो पता है टेक्निक होती है कौन सी
टेक्निक क्या होती है की आप मैसेंजर उसे
कर सकते हो जो उसका मैसेंजर है ना आपके
पास फर्स्ट नाम लास्ट नाम है तो उसको क्या
करो सिंपली मैसेंजर में क्या करता हूं
सर्च कर दो मैसेंजर में सर्च करोगे आपके
पास एक लिस्ट ए जाएगी मैं ये भी इनफॉरमेशन
देखने को मिलती है की उसका इंस्टाग्राम
अकाउंट है या नहीं है वो आपको देखने को
मिल जाता है कई बार देखने को मिल जाता है
उससे भी आप कंफर्म कर सकते हो डिस्कवर में
देखने को मिलता है एक तो लिस्ट ए जाति है
उसके बाद एक डिस्काउंट राहत है डिस्कार्ड
में आपको इंस्टाग्राम देखने को मिल जाता
है तो एक ये तरीका है दूसरा अब मैं आपको
लेकर चला हूं कुछ टूल्स हैं कुछ टूल्स हैं
पर एग्जांपल एक टूल है आपका की जो आपको
खुद से उसे करना चाहिए वैसे भाई ये एक
नंबर वन है ये रहा मेरा ये कौन सा है
एक तू लिए है एक टूल में आपको एक 1/1
बताता हूं आपको ये रहा ये रहा एक ये है
आपका प्रोफाइल करके आपकी जो उसमें मिला
होगा की गेट अप पे है एक मिस्टर नोज नोज
प्रोफाइल प्रोफाइल
आपको देखने को मिल रहा होगा एक मिनट ये ये
जस्ट को कंट्रोल नहीं करता हूं ये टूल
आपका क्या करना है सिंपली अगर आपको
इंस्टॉल करना नहीं आता मैं आपको बता देता
हूं यहां पे इंटर कीजिए
लोन करना है यहां पे कॉपी करना है उसके
बाद आपको क्या करना है जस्ट सिंपली आपको
अपना टर्मिनल ओपन करना है और उसके बाद
क्या करना है
पहले आपको क्या करना है की अगर आप चाहे तो
अपना खुद से क्या कर सकते हो
की फेसबुक ओपन सोर्स इंटेलिजेंट टूल्स
उसके अंदर उसको गेट कर लीजिए गेट क्लोन
कैसे करते हैं एग्जांपल मैंने क्या किया
हुआ है अभी मैं अलेक्स करता हूं तो मेरा
एक यहां पे ओपन किया हुआ है
अबॉर्शन इंटर करता हूं आपको देखने को
मिलेगा
ये रहा ऐसे देखो ऐसे जैसे
इंटर करोगे तो आप क्या करोगे सक्सेसफुली
यहां पर जैसे मैंने इंटर किया तो ये दिखा
रहा है अभी ऑलरेडी एग्जिट करता है क्योंकि
मैंने यहां पर पहले से डाउनलोड किया हुआ
है आप ऐसे ही डाउनलोड कर सकते हो
आप ऐसे डाउनलोड करोगे उसके बाद आपको क्या
करना है एडिट करना है और क्योंकि देखो ये
सारे स्टेप्स यहां पे भी मेंशन है अगर
आपको लगता है ये साइज टाइप यहां पे मेंशन
आपको सिंपली क्या करना था एवर क्लोन कर
लिया गिफ्ट क्लोन के बाद आपको क्या करना
है
पेस्ट कर दो उसके बाद इंस्टॉल करने के बाद
ये कर सकते हो सीडी प्रोफाइल
कर दो आपको सेटअप फाइल इंस्टॉल कर दो उसके
बाद इसको उसे करना कैसे है ये आपको इस
तरीके से देखने को मिलेगा जैसे मैं क्या
करूंगा इसको मैं एलएस करता हूं अभी पाइथन
थ्री प्रोफाइल
पाइथन 3
प्रोफाइल
देना पड़ेगा
फाइनल प्रोफाइल वाइफ
उसे कर सकते हो उसके साथ हिफिन एस उसे
करोगे तो हेल्प फाइल आपको देखने को मिल
जाएगी जिसमें अगर लाइनेक्स नहीं आता तो
प्लीज हमारे सीरीज पे जाइए काफी हेल्प
करेगा जैसे देखने मिलते हैं उसके बाद
हिफिन पी प्रोफाइल देना पड़ेगा आपको
प्रोफाइल देने के लिए आपके सिंपली क्या कर
सकते हैं यहां से काफी कुछ इनफॉरमेशन
निकाल सकते हो उसके ईमेल एड्रेस आपको और
भी मल्टीपल अकाउंट्स पे आपको देखने को मिल
जाएंगे पहले उसे पर्टिकुलर कीवर्ड के साथ
हिफिन पी दिया है मैंने और मेरे पास मैंने
यहां पर क्या किया है सर्च किया मार्क
जुकरबर्ग और हिट इंटर कर दिया मैंने
मार्क्स इंटर कर दिया अब ये क्या करना है
यहां पर आपको सिलेक्ट करना है की सेपरेटर
कौन सा रखना डॉट सेपरेटर रखना है या दास
सेपरेटर रखना है या अंडरस्कोर सेपरेटर
रखना है मैं अभी डॉट सेपरेटर रख रहा हूं
तो यार इसके लिए आपका कहना देखो अब डॉ
करने के लिए यहां पर क्या है अप डॉ अरा है
उसके बाद सिलेक्ट करने के लिए आपको स्पेस
उसे करना है मैं सिलेक्ट किया ये फर्स्ट
वाला सिलेक्ट कर लिया उसके बाद मैं का
दिया अब यहां पे ये बोल रहा है की आप इस
नाम से क्या-क्या इनफॉरमेशन निकालना था तो
उसका डोमेन नाम या ईमेल मी ईमेल शेर करना
चाहता हूं इंटरनेट
फॉर्म्स में नो पोस्टिंग देखना नो मनी
प्रोग्राम
चेक करना चाहता हूं क्या मैंने इसको
सिलेक्ट किया उसके बाद में फेसबुक पे सर्च
करना चाहता हूं क्लिक करते हैं
इंस्टाग्राम पे लिंक परी पे मी स्पेस सब
पे सर्च करना चाहता हूं टीचर देखना चाहता
हूं क्या ये सारे सिलेक्ट करने के लिए
आपको क्या करना पड़ेगा उसके बाद सिंपली
आपको हिट इंटर कर देना भैया आपको उसके
बड़े में इनफॉरमेशन कहते हैं स्टार्ट करना
स्टार्ट कर देगा शुरू कर देगा अभी देखिए
इसके बड़े में कुछ इनफॉरमेशन आपको शो
करेगा ईमेल्स की कुछ और मल्टीप्लेक्स
अकाउंट के बड़े में इस नाम से जुड़ा हुआ
है
टाइप ए नो रिजल्ट और आपको देखिए यहां पर
क्लिक करते
हैं 97 है तो काफी कुछ इनफॉरमेशन
देखने को मिल रही है आपको ये इनफॉरमेशन
कहते हैं आपको शो करना है अभी उसके बाद तो
उसको कैसे उसे करना है ये आपके डिपेंड
करता है मैंने आपको टूल बता दिया या टूल
अपना कम कर रहा है नेक्स्ट चलते हैं अब हम
अब यह सच्ची का रहा है फेसबुक पर इतनी
आईडी मिली है इससे रिलेटेड और उसके बाद
क्या पिंटू
देख रहा है ये उसके बाद आगे ईमेल्स
मिलेंगे तो इमेज भी फाइंड आउट करके दे
देगा ये आपके सामने हर कोई ईमेल मिलेगी ना
तो ईमेल भी फाइंड आउट करके दे देगा आपको
तब तक और टूल्स के बड़े में आपको
इनफॉरमेशन देता हूं पर एग्जांपल देखो आपके
पास जो आपका टारगेट है आपके पास टारगेट की
क्या प्रोफाइल है
उसके बाद प्रोफाइल है
प्रोफाइल पिक्चर है तो इसकी बेसिस पे क्या
कर सकते हो आप एनसी कर सकते हो
की ये प्रोफाइल के साथ कहां-कहां
जगह है पर इस प्रोफाइल को शेर किया है वो
साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन या फाइंड आउट कर सकते हैं
उसके लिए भी कुछ टूल्स हैं वो सब आपको उसे
करना है आपको लिस्ट मिल गई है अब मैं आपको
दिखता हूं एक यह रहा
ओम नाम चेकअप कंट्रोल सी करते हैं ओके ओके
ओके
मैं पहले आपको यह नहीं है
यहां पर इंटर करता हूं
और कंट्रोल भी कीजिए
ओपन करके देखिए यहां पे सिंपली क्या कर
सकते हो आपको पहले क्या पिक्चर क्या करने
पड़ेगी अपलोड करनी होगी यहां पर कोई भी
पिक्चर अपलोड करोगे तो उसके उसके बड़े में
यहां पर रिजल्ट आपको से कर देगा नेक्स्ट
एक और चीज है
वो सब्सक्राइब कम कर रहा है देखो टूल आपको
देखने को मिलेगा ये रहा ये है
ये भी से तू ली है लगभग
कंट्रोल सी करता हूं तो इसमें भी आपको
फोटो अपलोड करनी है उसकी बेसिक पे आपको
रिजल्ट देखने को मिलेगा ये आप लोगों का कम
है आप लोग मेरे को दिखाओगे की कौन कैसे
रिजल्ट फाइंड आउट कर का रहा है किस तरह की
इन्फॉर्म क्योंकि देखो जब तक आप किसी टूर
पे उसे नहीं करोगे ना तब तक आप उसके बड़े
में पता ही नहीं कर सकते हो उसे कैसे किया
जाता है ये दो टूल्स हैं यहां पर फोटो
अगर आपका कोई टारगेट है बहुत ही छोटा
टारगेट है एग्जांपल की दो कर पांच लोग का
टारगेट आप उसको टारगेट करके बैठे हुए
प्रैक्टिस के लिए तो क्या करूं लिमिटेड
फोटो ही होंगे तो हर एक फोटो क्या करो ना
उसको इन्हीं टूल्स का उसे करके इमेज
रिवर्स इमेज सर्च कर लो इन आईटी टूल का
उसे करके तो आपको पता चल जाएगा इस फोटो को
कहां-कहां उसे किया गया है हो सकता है की
उसने खुद उसे नहीं किया लेकिन किसी ने
उसका फोटो तो उसे किया होगा तो कहां पर
शेर किया है तो वो इनफॉरमेशन आपको जिसके
साथ मिल जाएंगे उसमें क्लिक करके दे सकते
हो कोई सोशल मीडिया पर या कहानी दूसरी जगह
पर आपको देखने को मिल जाएगा यहां पर
नेक्स्ट आपको अगर आपको ये पता करना है की
कीबोर्ड के बेसिस पर की कहां-कहां पर जो
कीबोर्ड है जो पर्टिकुलर कीवर्ड है पर
एग्जांपल
केवल का अकाउंट कहां-कहां पर है इस पर
टेबल कीवर्ड का अकाउंट कहां पर कहां पर है
क्योंकि देखो आपको एग्जैक्ट नाम नहीं पता
लेकिन वो फाइंड आउट करना चाहते हो
पार्टिकल की शब्द अब मल्टीप्लेक्स हो सकते
हैं वो मल्टीप्लेक्स कम हो सकते हैं अगर
आपके पास
यूजरनेम एग्जैक्ट यूजर नाम है अगर आपके
पास एग्जैक्ट यूजर नाम है किसी भी टारगेट
का तो एक्सेट यूजर नाम आप यहां पर करो
सिंपली का रहे हो एक ये है व्हाट मैं
नेम्स डॉट अप करके है यहां पर जैसे करोगे
यहां पर सिंपली उसका है नाम प्रेस करो मैं
क्या करूं अभी मार्क पेस्ट कर रहा हूं
ओन्ली मार्क और सिंपली यहां पर क्या कर
देना आपको सर्च कर देना है जैसे आप सर्च
करोगे इतने स्टार्ट करना शुरू कर दिया ये
आपको शो कर रहा है की कहां-कहां पर इसका
अकाउंट मिला है इस नाम से मार्क नाम से
देखो 581 को अपनी डेटाबेस को चेक कर रहा
है देखो यहां पर देखो देव डॉट टी ओ
हाइपरलिंक के गेम डिबेट इन पे सब पे इनको
अकाउंट मिला है एक यहां पर ये इनफॉरमेशन
आपको देखने को मिल रही है देखो यार ये रही
यह साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन
को क्लिक करता हूं तो आपको देखने को
मिलेगा
कम चले ना करें लेकिन यहां पर
देखो यहां पर ये मार्क नाम से देखना देखने
को मिल रहा है कुछ ना कुछ तो मिला है तो
ये हर जगह आपको फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश
करेगा एक ये टूल है दूसरा टूल आप कौन सा
उसे कर सकते हैं एक और है ये तो तीन आई हो
गया एक ये हो गया एक टूल आपका नाम
checkup.com ये टूल है यहां पर भी सिंपली
आप क्या करोगे जब मार्क लिखोगे यहां पर
मैंने क्या है मार्च केवल टाइप किया अगर
आपके पास एग्जैक्ट यूजर नाम है तो सिंपली
मैंने क्लिक किया तो आपको देखना है यहां
पर देखने को मिलेगा यहां पर ये रहा यहां
पर जो रेडमी है ये रेड में दिखाई दे रहे
हैं अकाउंट नहीं है
और जो येलो में दिखाई दे रहे हैं मतलब
यहां पर अकाउंट मिला नहीं है ग्रीन में
इन्हीं जगह पर इस नाम से अकाउंट है और
अबाउट मी और यहां पर अकाउंट्स जैसे फेसबुक
में ओपन करता हूं देखो जस्ट नाम से यहां
पे देखने को मिल रहा है देखो जग नाम से
फेसबुक अकाउंट देखो वही आया वही आया जो
मैं बोल रहा था जब नाम से तू तो ये कैसे
कम कर रहा है यहां पे हाईलाइट हो रहा है
आपको बेसिकली ध्यान ग्रीन और ये लाइट पिंक
है इस पे ध्यान देना है तो इससे आपको
क्लिक करके देख सकते हो क्योंकि काफी जगह
ऐसी होगी जहां पर लोग इन चाहिए होगा हम
आपको लोग इन क्या होगा तो डायरेक्टली उसको
ओपन करके दिखा देगा यहां पर कई जगह जल
पॉजिटिव है बट आपको ट्राई करके देखना है
की क्या आपको देखने को क्या-क्या देखने को
मिल रहा है यहां पर अब टेलीग्राम पे तो
मिलन ही है मिलन ही नहीं है क्योंकि भैया
पहले बात तो ये येलो में आया है तो एक ये
वेबसाइट है ये भी कम कर रही है नेक्स्ट
आपको दो बता दिया मैंने नेक्स्ट है थर्ड
ये हो गया फोर्थ हो गया अब एक पीना ही हो
गया
आपको काफी कुछ इनफॉरमेशन गैलरी में हेल्प
करता है और खास करके कौन सी इनफॉरमेशन
गैदरिंग में आपके फ्रेंड्स लिस्ट फाइंड
आउट करने में आपके फ्रेंड फाइंड आउट करने
में कोशिश है हेल्प करता है ये कौन सा टूल
है ये रहा एक है ये आपको जब ओपन करोगे
इसको भी गिफ्ट करना होगा आपको डाउनलोड
करना है से प्रोसेस है आपको सिंपली बोर्ड
पे जाना है आपको गिफ्ट क्लोन करना है और
गेट को ऑन करने के बाद ये रहा एफबीआई करके
फेसबुक इनफॉरमेशन
गैदरिंग जो सेंसेटिव इनफॉरमेशन कैन बी
इजीली गदर एवं
प्राइवेसी ये देखने को मिलेगा आपको सबसे
पहले क्या करना है एप्ट अपडेट करना है
अपग्रेड करना अपनी मशीन को उसके बाद अप
इंस्टॉल
कंट्रोल आईफोन
ये इस तरीके से चलेगा ये उसका आउटपुट है
तो मैं मैंने क्या ऑलरेडी अपनी मशीन में
डाउनलोड किया हुआ है मैं आपको इसका
इंटरफेस दिखा देता हूं ये देखो इसने क्या
है पहले देखो इनफॉरमेशन इसमें से भी कर दी
है जेसन फॉर्मेट में भी एचटीएमएल की में
भी अब देखो कितनी ईमेल एड्रेस देखने को
मिली है देखो ब्रिज देखो ये यहां भी
इनफॉरमेशन प्रोवाइड करके बीच भी है क्या
कोई मेल देखो मार्क @ gmail.com ये ब्रिज
मिली है बाकी शॉप है अभी तक ये साड़ी
एक्टिवा माइल्स की इनफॉरमेशन तो आपको यहां
पर ईमेल आईडी की भी इनफॉरमेशन देखने को
मिलने में अगर आपको जूम करके दिखाऊं अगर
जूम करके मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं ये आपको
जूम करके दिखा देता हूं
देखिए ये था आपका जूम करके मैंने आपको शो
कर दिया अभी मैं करता हूं बैक चला हूं
सीडी अब मैं एलएस करता हूं अब मैं सीधी
करता हूं
कैसे चला है और ल एस करता हूं यहां पर और
उसके बाद में पाइथन 3 शुरू करता हूं मैं
पाइथन 3 उसके बाद आपको देखना पड़ेगा
मतलब उसके रिमोट ओपन बोर्ड क्लियर हेल्प
अबाउट एक्साइट्स अभी मैं मेरे पास कोई
टारगेट नहीं है रियली में मेरे पास सच में
ही कोई टारगेट नहीं है तो मैं क्या कर रहा
हूं
जब मेरे पास टारगेट नहीं है तो मैं क्या
करूंगा सिंपली
आपको सबसे पहले क्या करना होगा इसको उसे
करने के लिए आपको पहले क्या करना होगा
इसमें टॉप के एड करना होगा आपको टोकन एड
करने के लिए क्या करना होगा
ओके और टोकन किया
आपके फेसबुक अकाउंट
इंटर कर देना है उसके बाद क्या है जेनरेट
एक्सेस टोकन फेल तू जेनरेट एक्सेस टोकन
क्योंकि आपने ईमेल आईडी पासवर्ड
जब एक बार टोकन जेनरेट हो जाएगा आपको
सिंपली फिर क्या करना है गेट डाटा करना है
तो क्या कर देगा कैचिंग जो फ्रेंड्स डाटा
पर एग्जांपल जी भी आईडी को आप क्या करना
फेस कर रहे हो उसके सारे फ्रेंड्स का डाटा
आपको देखने को मिल जाएगा अभी आया गेट डाटा
यहां पर सारे फ्रेंड्स के डाटा आपको देखना
है क्योंकि हमने जो लॉगिन किया था मेरे
सारे फ्रेंड्स का डाटा मिल जाएगा एडरवाइज
आप क्या कर सकते हो की यहां पर मेंशन कर
सकते हो यहां पर आईडी मेंशन कर सकते हो
यहां पर आप मन मेंशन कर सकते हो डंप आईडी
दम आईडी करोगे
तो इस तरीके से क्या है इस टूल को आप उसे
करना सिख लो यहां पे लिखा हुआ है और इसमें
क्या है की ये देखो आ बेसिकली का गेट
इन्फो करोगे सो इनफॉरमेशन अबाउट योर
फ्रेंड आपके फ्रेंड्स के बड़े में
इनफॉरमेशन शो करेगा और फ्रेंड्स दम फोन
नंबर भी डंप कर दिया अगर पब्लिक के लिए
अवेलेबल होगा तो मेल भी ईमेल भी अगर
पब्लिकली अवेलेबल होगी तो प्राइवेट नहीं
की होगी तो यहां पर क्या है फीजिंग जो
आईडी फ्रॉम योर फ्रेंड्स पूसी फाइट अब
क्या कर सकते हैं यहां पर डंप कर सकते हैं
यहां पर आईडी मेंशन करोगे इसके बीच में आप
क्या कर सकते हो आईडी मैसेज करोगे
रिमूव कर सकते हैं बोट का मतलब क्या है की
आपने जिसके साथ टोकन जेनरेट किया हुआ है
जी भी आइडिया का टोकन जेनरेट किया हुआ है
उसे आईडी में क्या करोगे आप
उसे आईडी को उसके फ्रेंड्स की जो पोस्ट
उसको डिलीट भी कर सकते हो वो भी कर सकते
हो बट क्या है की इसमें अभी कम चल रहा है
अभी टूल में क्या है कुछ ऑप्शन जो बोट
वाला ऑप्शंस में आपको बहुत साड़ी देखने को
मिलेगी मैंने इस पे कम किया था क्योंकि
इसमें अभी अपडेट करना होगा उससे अगर किसी
को पाइथन स्क्रिप्टिंग आई है तो उसको
ऑपरेट कर सकता है एडरवाइज आपको सबसे
ज्यादा मतलब इन्हीं सही है क्योंकि देखो
सब कुछ क्लीयरली एक्सप्लेन किया हुआ है
तो इनफॉरमेशन अबाउट इनफॉरमेशन
देखो कमांड टाइप हेल्प
ओके
उसमें भी आपको हर जगह एक बार लॉगिन करना
पड़ेगा आपको अपनी आईडी से इस के बेसिस पे
आप क्या है इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग कर सकते हो
तो ये टूल्स हैं जिसका नाम यहां पर
इन्होंने खेल लिखा हुआ है तो दो टूल्स
मैंने आपको बताया है उसके बाद मैंने कितने
टूल्स बता दिए की आपको जो लिस्ट प्रोवाइड
की है पर एग्जांपल काफी अच्छे टूल्स के
रिश्तो तो आज हम क्या कर देंगे जो फेसबुक
ओपन सोशल इंटेलिजेंस है यही पर फिनिश कर
देते हैं आई होप मुझे एक बात बता दिया यस
या नो समझ में आया या नहीं आया
जो मैंने आपको टूल्स बताए हैं कौन-कौन से
टूल्स हैं
और उसके बाद ये
मिनी की क्रीम की क्रीम की मैंने आपको बता
दिया जिसमें आप फोटो अपलोड करके इनफॉरमेशन
कर सकते हो
मैंने बता दिया जिसमें आप क्या कर सकते हो
कोई भी अगर यूजरनेम आपके पास ठीक है अगर
नाम नहीं है आपके पास फर्स्ट नाम लास्ट
नाम आपको भी किया शब्द है उसके बेसिस पे
पता कर सकते हो कहां-कहां पर इस नाम से
अकाउंट बने हुए हैं वो एक में तो काफी
डिटेल पर उसके बाद प्रोफाइल दो करके बड़े
में आपको बता दिया बेस 64 कोडर के बड़े
में बता दिया
इसमें फॉर्मेट के बड़े में बता दिया ये वो
फाइल जिसके बेसिस पर क्या करोगे आपके सारे
यू आर मैनिपुलेशन करोगे यह जो
फॉर्मेट है जो ऐसे कम करता है अगर आपको
पढ़ना तो ऐसे पढ़ सकते हो उसके बाद 100
साल से इनफॉरमेशन और अगर आप टिप्स इंडेक्स
डॉट आए हो ये सारे वो टूल्स मैंने आपको
बता दिया क्योंकि अगर ये टूल्स कम नहीं
करते हैं तब ये आपका कम जो है ये ये तो
100% कम करेगा ये करेगा उसके बाद ये टूल्स
भी एक्टिव है उसके बाद ये है आप चाहे तो
इतने टूल्स पर उसे कर सकते हैं अभी तक
मैंने इतने टूल्स इनफॉरमेशन आपको प्रोवाइड
कर दिए आप चाहे तो स्क्रीनशॉट ले लीजिए
अगर आप किसी को नहीं मिला
अगर चाहते हो आप स्क्रीनशॉट ले लीजिए
प्लीज मुझे बता दीजिए की आप सबको समझ में
आया नहीं आया बस ये बता दीजिए की आपको समझ
में आया या नहीं आया बस ये बता दीजिए हम
क्या करते हैं
देखिए लैपटॉप की बात करें तो लैपटॉप में
मिनिमम आपके पास वी-फी होना चाहिए और
मिक्स मिनिमम राम ज्यादा हनी चाहिए 16gb
रैम हनी चाहिए अगर आप अच्छे जो हैकिंग
प्रैक्टिकल करना चाहते हो और प्रोग्रामिंग
भी साथ में करें और अच्छा ग्राफिक कार्ड
मिनिमम चार्ज भी तो ग्राफिक कार्ड चाहिए
अगर आप अच्छे हैकिंग प्लेटफॉर्म पर चलाना
चाहते हैं तो आपके लिए बॉक्स ऑफिस में
मल्टीपल मशीन चलाना चाहते तो मिनिमम आपको
चाहिए चाहिए और लैपटॉप में हमेशा सब पेपर
को देखो मैं किसी कंपनी को पेपर नहीं
करूंगा क्योंकि कंपनी डिपेंड नहीं करती
लैपटॉप में क्योंकि फाइनल में आपका कम
क्या होता है फाइनल में आपका कम होता है
हैकिंग फील्ड में या प्रोग्रामिंग फील्ड
में प्रोग्रामिंग फिल्म में दोनों में
क्या है सबसे फाइनल कम किसका राहत है
प्रोसेसिंग का राहत है आपको सबसे ज्यादा
क्या चाहिए होगा प्रोसेसिंग प्रोसेसिंग के
लिए आपको क्या चाहिए एक तो राम चाहिए और
वो चाहिए
क्योंकि अभी अभी रिसेंटली
हमने एक ब्लॉक डाला हुआ ना तो प्लीज युटुब
पर जाइए
[संगीत]
आपको लैपटॉप कौन सा परचेज करना चाहिए क्या
होना चाहिए
आप गाइड ले सकते हो लेकिन मैं बता देता
हूं आपका एक अच्छा प्रोसेस चाहिए होता है
आपको एथिकल हैकिंग करने के लिए एक ग्राफिक
कार्ड चाहिए होता है ग्राफिक अच्छा खास का
चार्ज भी 6 जीबी मिनिमम तो चाहिए चाहिए 6
जीबी तो 16 जीबी रैम रखो i5 मिनिमम
प्रोसेस होना चाहिए i5 मिनिमम है अगर i7
हो तो आप अच्छा है
अच्छी बात है बट i5 मिनिमम चाहिए तो यह
आपकी रिटायरमेंट फूल फूल कर सकता है या
ऐसा नहीं की एक पेन ड्राइव के बेस पे कुछ
भी कर पाओगे ऐसा नहीं होता की बहुत लोग
क्या कर रहे हैं की मैंने देखा की वो एक
पेन ड्राइव में शायद टूल्स इंस्टॉल करके
बोला हमने खुद का बनाया है उसके बाद आप
उसको उसे कर सकते हो पेन ड्राइव कितनी
स्लो होती है भाई कितनी फास्ट होती है
और जस्ट
पैसे कमाने का तरीका
करना है या नहीं करना है क्योंकि बहुत कुछ
बच्चा हुआ है ये अब डिसाइड किया जाएगा
बैठकर
तो आज ही पता चल जाए आपको ग्रुप में अगर
डिसाइड होगा तो आपका फर्ज सेशन संडे को
होगा एडरवाइज आई कांत से एनीथिंग
यह आप फ्लिपकार्ट पर जाकर चेक कर लीजिए
ब्रो सही रहेगा
अच्छा रहेगा आपके लिए भी
कोई सीपी है
आप क्या करोगे
किसी से दिसंबर भी करवाओगे तो एक हो जाएगा